okay something completely predictable
is happening with so-called vaccine
passports
so-called mandatory vaccines and
this we predicted it weeks ago it didn't
require any special insights i didn't
need a crystal ball
i'm not some kind of soothsayer for
realizing this was going to happen
on the one hand we expected there would
be
schools businesses employers
airlines whatever that would start to
say
after a certain date if you want to do
business with us
if you want to go to school here etc you
will need to be vaccinated against
covid19 now that was our prediction at
the time it hadn't yet started to happen
we also were seeing some states arizona
was one that we mentioned at the time
but now there are more
that were decreeing bans
against mandatory vaccination or
so-called vaccine passport so for
example we covered last week or the week
before
that arizona governor doug ducey
defiantly said
we will not have any vaccine passports
here mandatory vaccine requirements but
of course
it only applies to state government and
to municipalities
tucson can't require every tucson
resident get vaccinated but of course
that was never going to happen however
we are seeing
more and more some employers but many
many schools we now have more than 100
u.s colleges and universities that are
saying to come back to campus in the
fall
you need to be vaccinated against
coronavirus there's nothing legally
complicated about it
before the pandemic when i went to
college i had to show proof of
certain vaccinations i don't remember
exactly hepatitis and
i needed a you know a tetanus shot
booster whatever there's been a list
this has been going on for a very long
time
and exactly what we predicted is
happening and what is that
that people in some of these states
because now you have in addition to
arizona you have the arkansas governor
signing into law
measures preventing governments from
requiring vaccination but this is not
about
governments requiring it texas south
dakota
idaho you know all these florida all
these different states are signing
different things
banning required vaccination but it only
applies to government and some
very narrow other situations so you are
starting to see
the posts are all over the internet
they're all over my twitter every time i
tweet about vaccines they're all in the
comments every time you read about
oh uh this university will require
vaccination that one will for on campus
students people commenting and saying
this is illegal the governor already
banned it
this was written on the wall go back to
my commentary from when we talked about
arizona issuing a ban on vaccine
requirements
and i said you were going to have these
anti-vaxx people showing up
saying you can't do this because the
governor banned it and of course the
governor's orders
do not apply to colleges and
universities
and you know ticketmaster and live
nation or
if the phoenix suns in arizona their bat
the basketball team wants to say to come
to
to games you have to have proof of
vaccination or they might say you need
proof of vaccination or you've got to
take a negative test
if you're not vaccinated these are two
different things and we knew that they
were going to start confusing them
either deliberately
or be because they don't actually
understand
the limits of what government can and
cannot decree here one thing has nothing
to do with the other
it was predictable that it would create
chaos
and we're not even at the point where
kids are starting to go back to school
yet
by the time that fall comes we hopefully
will be
closer to herd immunity there are
concerns as to whether we will ever get
there
but we we will we should be closer if
not actually there i think we will be
doing very well as far as cases and
deaths go by that point in time
everybody who wants a vaccine by far
will have been able to get one we're
getting close to that and now it's about
convincing people
to want to get the vaccine way more
colleges and universities and maybe
airlines and maybe other venues and
businesses and on and on
hospitals whatever will have said in
order to work here
in order to attend school here in order
to patronize our services that we offer
you will need to have proof of
vaccination and they are going to be
going absolutely nuts how does this get
solved i have no idea
i have no idea the the level of
misunderstanding
and it's predictable listen it's true
that
even people who aren't particularly
ignorant if you don't follow this stuff
closely and you hear
you know arizona arizona governor bans
mandatory vaccines
and meanwhile arizona state university
says you've got to be vaccinated to come
to campus
that does sound like a conflict in some
sense and it requires
understanding that what the arizona
governor passed applies only to
a city can't require being vaccinated to
go to the dmv or deny you
dmv services that type of thing it does
not apply to arizona arizona state
university or whatever else
it was completely predictable it's going
to be absolute chaos and i think there
is going to be
probably as travel starts to open in
other countries there are already other
countries that are leaning in the
direction of saying
if american travelers if any travelers
want to come here you will need to be
vaccinated
this is likely to reach a fever pitch in
july into august and as we get close to
the fall semester
there's going to be protests there's
going to be absolute and total chaos and
it was completely
predictable all along one of our
sponsors is privacy.com they're giving
you five dollars when you sign up for
their completely
free service at privacy.com pacman i've
been using privacy for a little over a
year now you've heard me talk about it
before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy
something online or on the phone instead
of actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app
and the browser plug-in let you give
each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information
so this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches
and identity theft and it's free and
like i said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com pacman